you guys have all known each other for a
while so stalkers are briefs No hey I'm
Tamar Krinsky pure for Earth's Mightiest
show you've got to know your cast
members really well at this point so we
want to know the real secrets behind
Marvel Studios Avengers and game who's
the worst secret keeper ruffles the
worst that's no question mark is bad oh
yeah oh yeah sorry I forgot my mark I
love you mark
I mean blatantly it looks like I'm
giving you a secret but it isn't really
he's pretty good I think Robert is the
best secret keeper it's true he's got
the longest yeah who else's costume
would you want to try it if you could I
like your costume the best oh yeah all
right on some scared you don't want it
not gonna be the same if it were real
Iron Man's I don't have a desire to do
that no if it takes a while and mine
actually is one of the easiest costumes
is this difficult if yours is one of the
easiest I choose Hawkeye America mean
about your biceps or do they augment
that a little bit movie magic mark movie
magic amazing who's the best answer Paul
Rudd would say it would be Paul Rudd hmm
but I'm sure it's me oh but Chris Evans
are you done sir do I go just like
buster attack routine and I'm like what
can you do
Ignatz mm-hmm shall we who's got the
best beard a lot of manscaping going on
hard to beat the words got a really good
here yeah Danny is a very manicured
that's true I appreciate that
who's the most likely to snooze on set I
think I know I do comes
for sure I can sleep anywhere yeah yeah
I can sleep under the table pad down and
just lay down
sometimes it's obviously been an
incredible journey through the Marvel
Cinematic Universe what is the most
important thing along the way that you'd
like to say to the fans a massive thank
you oh man thank you so much for this
ride it's been amazing you guys are
great
couldn't be happier and more humbled by
your dedication to this world it's great
word dedication that's what it is it's
been a crazy ride you know the process
of doing Black Panther and seeing how
something gets marveled you know what I
mean you're like oh my god the coolest
I've ever seen it's been a literal dream
come true for us to be able to work with
these characters to tell these stories
you know we grew up fans so for us to be
able to have this opportunity to bring
these stories to audiences it's been
it's been a thrill and like we've been
so immersed in it it's it's been our
lives the past seven years
Wow thank you so much we cannot wait to
see Marvel Studios ventures and game in
theaters on April 26 oh man our course
wanted tomorrow Krinsky clearly had a
blast talking with the cast and
directors of Marvel Studios Avengers
endgame but Langston and I are also here
partying it up every week on Earth's
Mightiest show that's right Laraine we
are always talking about the most epic
stuff in the Marvel Universe Nell the
rain there's a lot of fun to be had
there was your favorite part
oh man I just love the Mark Ruffalo
can't keep a secret you know that he
can't keep a secret because he can't he
it might make him angry yeah true story
I guess that's Bruce Banner I like that
I mean I don't know I really love seeing
the cast hanging out together I love I
also have the idea that they like to
dance they like that Chris Evans likes
to dance
Chris Hemsworth one's real argent and
Don Cheadle very nicely accommodating
what a great host I go to the his gallop
gallop Oh Don Cheadle invite us over
yeah nice war machine armed with a black
tie of you lovely stay tuned to Earth's
Mightiest show for even more on Marvel
Studios Avengers endgame and all the
other awesome Marvel goodness that you
love by making sure you subscribe to the
Marvel YouTube channel yeah and be sure
to like Earth's Mightiest show on the
official Facebook page where
we release extra special content
hilarious galleries and lots of other
cool stuff yes and we love hearing from
you too so let us know what you'd like
to see on a future episode of Earth's
Mightiest show in the comments and with
the hashtag Earth's Mightiest show yeah
we'll see you next week with a brand new
episode and in the meantime go get your
tickets to see Marvel Studios Avengers
endgame in theaters April 26 what are
you waiting for get on it right now come
on yeah I'm Lorraine I'm like certain
this is Marvel your universe thanks for
watching or some ideas show if you like
this like this leave us a comment and
subscribe to the Marvel channel or click
the box over there to watch our last
episode hey Lorraine tell me a secret